let's go to jimmy from rochester jimmy
you're on the air
hey david hello
hey you can hear me i can hear you fine
cool
um so
lately i've been thinking a lot about
how uh
a person's ethical philosophy kind of
informs
their political stances on things
and especially how difficult it is
to argue
with someone who doesn't share your
ethical philosophy sure so
for example
uh like a libertarian would say
that you should never coerce
anyone basically
and so if you don't agree with that like
that's why they
don't want to be taxed and that type of
thing well let me if i can jump in i
don't know that i necessarily agree with
the so with liberty i think
libertarians and non-libertarians alike
would often agree that coercion is bad
at a government level
the disagreement comes in what counts as
coercion for me that in the in your
particular example that seems to be the
greater dividing line
sure sure sure and and so
even
to take even a a
more obvious example like the
the growth of like the trump business
the trumpism and in the country yes um
if
how can you
it seems as as if
it's not that we both want to get
the country to the same place
but we have different ideas on how to
get there
it's like we want to get it to
completely different places correct
so what do you do with that you know
what i mean like how do you
how can you
debate someone or argue or persuade
someone
when it's that different
on individual issues sometimes what
you're so
you are a hundred percent correct that
the the thirty thousand foot vision for
the united states of america is very
different for a trumpist than a social
democrat you're completely correct but
sometimes at the issue level the end
goal is the same so like for example
you find a lot to pick just to pick
something if you think about abortion
many people on the left agree
they would love to reduce the number of
abortions and people on the right say
that they want the number to be zero the
difference is the people on the left
would say well let's reduce abortions by
making contraception widely available
teaching comprehensive sex education
making sure women know that if they do
have a kid
they're going to be able to afford all
of the associated costs whereas the
right says let's let's ban it and make
people ashamed for even thinking of it
so
that's an example where even though the
vision is different
if we can find some similarity in the
end goal
then we can engage as to how we most
effectively get there so some so i think
maybe what i'm saying is
while you're correct that the vision is
very different in different political
factions there might be some overlap in
the end goals with enough people on the
right that we could have some productive
conversations
that would be nice
it's it's a little bit pie in the sky
but at least it's it's an optimistic
perspective i guess
sure i mean yeah it's it
you have to start somewhere i suppose
yeah exactly
well i appreciate it alright thanks so
much for the call great to hear from you